Working in a morgue requires some specific
skills.
You need to be comfortable being around the
dead.
You need to have a great attention to detail.
And you’d better not be squeamish - you’ll
be getting up-close and personal with some
gruesome specimens.
But for those who find themselves in a specific
morgue under the supervision of the SCP foundation,
they’ll need to have some EXTRA specific
skills - if they hope to get out alive.
In the basement of an old hospital in Great
Britain, there is a morgue.
It appeared like any other until the 1980s,
with a busy hospital staff coming in and out
to investigate causes of death and perform
autopsies, reporting anything unique to the
doctors upstairs.
But soon, the morgue and the hospital around
it began to get a reputation.
People whispered that something wasn’t right
in the morgue, that there were supernatural
dealings afoot.
And soon, they were proven right.
Because what’s dead in SCP-022 doesn’t
always stay dead.
The Foundation soon stepped in and quarantined
the morgue, condemning the building.
An investigation didn’t find any cause for
the unpredictable and dangerous phenomena,
but the Foundation was able to track the pattern
of reanimations - and did happen upon the
following: The morgue is filled with body
storage drawers and at random times, the spontaneous
opening of one or several of them will occur.
And despite the fact that the morgue has been
out of operation for quite a long while, whenever
a drawer opens, there is a body laying inside
under a sheet every time.
And after six minutes of being opened, the
body will wake up.
When awake, these reanimated corpses have
exactly one mission - to get out of the morgue
by any means necessary.
If the corpse is relatively intact, it will
leap off the table and charge at the door
- and anything else in its way.
While no specimen has ever been safely captured
for testing, their base strength seems to
be far stronger than any normal human.
No evidence of what gives them this power
has been found, but they are absolutely formidable
and very hard to stop.
And to add to the difficulty...They’re even
harder to kill a second time around.
While all evidence indicates that these are
reanimated humans, they do not seem to be
limited by the same physical effects of damage.
Those who have tried to stop these undead
beings from getting to the door have found
this out the hard way.
These cadavers seem to be immune to just about
any form of impairment.
Their bodies don’t give off heat, and they
do not need to eat, drink, or breathe.
If their bodies are severely damaged, the
body part with the greatest mass stays active
and doesn’t seem to slow down at all.
Only one thing actually seems to impede upon
the horrifying persistence that these cadavers
portray in their attempts to escape… fire.
The Foundation has discovered that fire may
be the one effective way of stopping the undead
specimens - but it’s not as easy as simply
setting them on fire.
High-powered fire is needed, to incinerate
their tissue and render them little more than
a pile of ash.
The good news is, there is another method
to neutralize them - and that’s to wait
them out.
If the corpse is active but contained by the
Foundation's security, they will eventually
expire when whatever power is animating them
finally runs out - but this can take between
two days and three weeks, which can be problematic
if they’re joined by other friends from
the drawers.
But not all of the living corpses follow the
same pattern.
Bodies emerge in the drawers seemingly at
random, and the state they arrive in is just
as unpredictable.
This may correspond to how they died, and
an investigation is ongoing in regard to how
these corpses wind up in the morgue to begin
with.
Some arrive in good shape, as if they were
recently deceased from a heart attack or other
similar ailment.
These are the most dangerous specimens.
Others may be decomposed or damaged, which
will cause them to be slower.
But some are in such poor condition that they
can’t get up off the slab at all.
And that’s where SCP-022 reacts in an unexpected
way.
The cadaver may be too damaged to move, but
it’s still reanimated, and will struggle
and twitch on the slab for whatever the duration
is of their reanimated life.
But if it expires while still on the slab,
the slab will act on its own, and slide back
into the drawer with the cadaver still on
it.
The body then disappears, and from what witnesses
have reported, a smell of burning tissue similar
to cremation then fills the air in the morgue.
No one knows where the corpses go - but perhaps
more importantly, where do they come from?
That is the one question that concerns the
Foundation the most about SCP-022.
While the main priority is to contain the
reanimated corpses, studying them is also
vital.
Unfortunately, testing on the reanimated is
limited due to their aggressive nature, however,
agents have been able to observe them just
enough to describe them and send the descriptions
out to law enforcement, as evidence shows
that SCP-022 may also be able to reach outside
of the confines of the morgue.
What the Foundation has learned from interfacing
with local law enforcement, is that every
single one resembles a corpse stolen from
a morgue around the country.
Studies of the specimens after they expire,
if not consumed by the drawers, is the easiest
way to conduct testing.
They can be examined safely and appear to
be standard human corpses with the only exception
being any damage done during the attempt by
the Foundation to contain them.
They don’t seem to have any unusual organs
or chemicals in the body, and no explanation
for their reanimation can be found.
There is however, one other element of SCP-022
that concerns researchers.
Nothing seems to be able to be added to the
morgue.
When something is placed into or enters the
room, it vanishes after only seconds.
This has happened to inanimate objects, as
well as to animals - and even to people.
There is no evidence as to where these specimens
go.
What makes this happen is unknown, but provides
further evidence for the theory that there
is definitely some dangerous anomaly governing
SCP-022, far beyond the fact corpses are simply
reanimating.
While the rest of the hospital that contains
SCP-022 has so far been free of anomalies
and is a standard abandoned building, an exploration
of the room above the morgue revealed something
concerning.
In the room, agents discovered a massive pile
of matter that seemed to be composed of all
the things that had vanished upon entering
SCP-022.
All of the metal objects had been broken down,
and the organic material had decomposed.
Everything looked like it had been there far
longer than the time since it had vanished,
despite appearing only three minutes after
its disappearance in testing.
But one thing was missing from the mystery
pile.
What happened to the people who had disappeared
inside the morgue?
None of the humans who disappeared, either
in accidents before the Foundation stepped
in or in testing, appeared in the pile in
decayed form.
But it wasn’t long before they appeared
in another way.
The Foundation observed that several of the
corpses that appeared from behind the drawers
of SCP-022 resembled the unfortunate citizens
who had disappeared into the room in the past.
The morgue’s victims had returned - and
they wanted out.
Now it was clear that the priority had to
be containment.
The door to the facility was destroyed during
a security breach by a particularly tenacious
specimen, so The Foundation installed a more
powerful vault door shortly after taking over
the facility, with orders that it must remain
locked at all times.
Because of the morgue’s ability to absorb
anything that enters it, containment of the
entities is dependent entirely on automated
systems.
If the cadavers happen to make it through
the vault door placed just outside of the
perimeter of the original SCP-022 room, awaiting
their arrival are the Foundation’s high-powered
automated fire weapons.
Once the undead cross the threshold of the
door, the weapons are triggered and incinerate
them immediately.
It is only if this system fails that response
teams are sent in to contain the threat, followed
by cleanup crews.
No humans are to enter SCP-022 unless further
testing is needed, nor is any entity to be
removed from the containment site.
While the first time the Foundation encountered
one of the reanimated corpses it had been
immediately destroyed, the second time was
a different story.
It appeared to be an Asian man in his fifties,
and its body was mostly intact with the exception
of a large chest scar that resembled that
of an autopsy.
It claimed its name was John, and remembered
dying in a car accident - but it refused to
admit that it was dead.
Then it saw its reflection, and things took
a disturbing turn.
While the specimen had remained calm until
then, it became extremely angry as soon as
it saw its image on the steel table and had
to be restrained.
While in containment, it claimed over and
over again that it was not the man it saw
in it’s reflection.
Whoever was in the body, didn't believe it
was the older Asian man.
It then became enraged, screaming and smashing
its head against a wall until it stopped talking
and eventually stopped moving all together.
No more information could be obtained.
What was SCP-022 doing to the people who appeared
in it?
The answer to that question became a little
clearer after the Foundation was able to capture
a specimen again.
This time it was shortly after a D-class designated
D-5619 had been sent into the morgue and immediately
disappeared.
What emerged from the drawer shortly thereafter,
though, wasn’t the D-class.
It was a little girl who looked to be about
twelve years old.
And just like the cadaver captured prior,
when restrained, it became extremely angry.
However, it did eventually cooperate in answering
questions for the Foundation.
It was soon identified as D-5619, the unfortunate
D-class testing victim.
It wasn’t long after that the question of
what happened to D-5619’s body was answered.
Three weeks following the incident, D-5619’s
body returned from the drawers - but it wasn’t
him inside of it.
A brief interview confirmed that this was
a very confused but overall cooperative 89-year-old
woman in the body of the D-class.
Whatever effect is going on within SCP-022,
it seems to return people in twisted, mismatched
combinations of body and mind.
The Foundation is still investigating exactly
what is happening inside of SCP-022, with
a focus on how the anomaly gets its corpses
from around Great Britain.
But when dealing with the mystery morgue itself,
the Foundation holds to a simple rule.
Nothing gets in - and nothing gets out.
For more on a mysterious threat in an unlikely
place, check out “SCP-974 - Treehouse Predator”,
or check out this other video instead for
more from SCP Explained.